[Music]
[Music]
this is a public service announcement
for all weebs affected by the current
coronavirus outbreak in the midst of all
the panic within the general populace
it's times like these we must come
together and ask what can we as weebs do
to protect ourselves from the outbreak
will things be daijoubu and most
importantly what can we learn from anime
about how to contain the spread of
coronavirus in anime sick anime girls
are the most adorable thing ever if
there's an anime girl with the high
fever and a guy walks in to take care of
her some poor girls anal cavity is about
to get rekt by suppository and of course
most importantly if an anime character
stays out in the rain for too long and
gets a cold you might as well have just
told them that they have stage 4
leukemia but many weebs may still be
confused as to how to handle the current
pandemic so let's start with the most
important advice you need to know step 1
don't fire the virus during the early
days of the outbreak while the World
Health Organization was warning for the
possible storms come with the virus the
anime community reacted pretty much the
only way they knew how to by seeing if
it was possible to stick their dick in
it so I repeat don't [ __ ] the virus red
blood cells are fine though we interrupt
this PSA to bring you a quick word from
our sponsor of gray hair step 2
don't panic one of the most important
things is to stay calm I mean we all
know how bad it is to overly panic from
movies or anime this is real life and
real life isn't as predictably stupid as
every disaster movie where some cliche
scientist dudes warning gets ignored by
every governments bigwig before an
impending disaster
we're not ready for the next epidemic
today the greatest risk of global
catastrophe looks like this if there's
one positive thing that can come out of
the Ebola epidemic it's that it can
serve as a early warming a wake-up call
to get ready if we start now we can be
ready for the next epidemic thank you
[Music]
when looking at pandemics and anime the
closest thing we can find is something
like high school for the dead but
unfortunately this probably would not be
the best resource to learn from as it's
pretty obvious this is not an accurate
representation of what a deadly outbreak
would actually be like because I mean
there isn't even a single scene where
survivors risked their lives fighting
through 40 infection desperately
searching through every store every
empty building because they ran out of
toilet paper to wipe their ass with
currently you're more likely to get
crying a virus than you are to get
toilet paper proving that reality is
nothing like the movies at all it's far
dumber step three social distancing
public health officials have warns that
the general public should do their best
to stay indoors avoid any unnecessary
travel stock up on necessary resources
and in general keep social interaction
to a bare minimum
I'm just gonna be the this is referred
to officially by the CDC as social
distancing self quarantine or being a
[ __ ] weed see while the rest of
society is figuring out how to function
without leaving the house self
quarantine is already a secret technique
inherited through generations of weaves
giving us the natural edge over the rest
of humankind in fact there are even
studies that have suggested that
masturbation is a healthy way to improve
one's immune system which could indicate
that the coronavirus is just Darwin's
natural selection in action and
degenerates weaves were the next stage
of human evolution this entire time this
is still currently just an untested
hypothesis step 4 understanding how to
prevent the spread knowledge is half the
battle and if you see someone who could
be sick with the coronavirus the first
thing to do is don't do that from what
we know the most common methods of
transmission are via sneezing coughing
direct human contact touching
contaminated surfaces and LimeWire if
you have access to one face masks can
help can avoid coughing or sneezing like
any other god [ __ ] damn it make sure
you avoid coughing or sneezing off make
sure you of all make sure can we all
just stop sneezing for one second as I
was saying I encourage everyone to keep
sneezing it's strongly advised against
hand holding as this will not only
reduce the transmission of the corona
virus but also stop the spread of anime
STDs and above all remember to wash your
hands regularly for at least 20 seconds
using the correct technique in a place
we call the sink I don't actually know
what a sink looks like sometimes the
simplest measures can help a lot but
please be aware that in 2020 clearing
your throat is still a normal bodily
function people do from time to time
[Applause]
yes the [ __ ] road of ironies be aware
that extreme steps have all been taken
to contain the spread and many public
events have been canceled many sporting
events have been canceled
III is canceled anime conventions are
canceled flying is canceled Logan Paul
is cancelled again probably in fact fun
is canceled
anyone seen having fun in 2020 will be
shot on sight not only that but many
places are in complete lockdown this
includes LA and San Francisco and as one
of the worst affected areas Italy has
been a lockdown for a short while now
let's have a peek at how they're
handling their quarantine this concludes
this public service announcement
there have been fears and this is still
not the most effective way to motivate
anime fans to change their lifestyle and
habit but there is a method that we can
guarantee that which is why we're happy
to announce the newest anime coming out
next season cute girls do coronavirus
things a lot of people are rightly
scared and many many people have been
affected by this but if we all work to
cooperate we can all get through this
together so if you are stuck at home in
quarantine with a lot of extra time in
your hands try to make the best of it
watch some anime play some games or
maybe even use it as an excuse to
reconnect with the ones you used to be
close with hey it's um it's it's me look
I know it's been a while since we last
saw each other
and I know it's been entirely my fault
I've just been busy you know and I know
that's no excuse I've neglected you all
this time I know I could have done
better look the world's gone crazy right
now and it's given me a lot of time to
really think about what's important to
me and what I really want to be spending
what I'm doing right now
I know I don't deserve your forgiveness
I know I don't deserve a second chance
but if you can find it in your heart to
give us another shots I promise this
times gonna be different I promise we're
gonna do things differently I promise
I'm gonna be there this time what do you
say
[Music]
go wash your hands right now
[Music]